this video is sponsored by klima click
the link in the description and use code
pursuit10 to receive 10 extra trees
planted in your name
on may 3rd 1948 at 2 39 am a girl named
arya corrin was born her parents james
and pauline looked down at their
firstborn baby with overwhelming wonder
love and nerves feeling each in forms
they never had before eager to witness
how their daughter would experience the
world on september 12 1948 james and
pauline realized something was wrong
at four months old arya still seemed
extremely detached and unresponsive when
they said things to her or made noises
at or around her she seemed to mostly
ignore or not notice them at first they
assumed it was normal nothing more than
the still developing awareness of an
embryonic mind but as more time had
passed they had become increasingly
concerned
on september 16 1948 just a few days
later it was discovered by arya's doctor
that she had been born deaf
by age two it was clear that arya was
the sort of death that was profound in
which no hearing aids would aid her in
any way
james and pauline were told that arya
would never hear anything
devastated by the thought of arya never
being able to hear their voices or have
her own hear birds chirp waves crash or
the sound of music pauline burst into
tears upon hearing the news james
consoled her trying to maintain a more
stoic demeanor but was nonetheless
tearing up and feeling the same
as arya grew into a young child she
would live a relatively normal life in
the best way she could she performed
well in school was excellent at arts and
navigated childhood social life of
course all of this and daily life in
general was made uniquely challenging
and nuanced for her although she adapted
fairly well being as positive and
resilient as she could she was often
extremely frustrated and upset by her
deafness
like other girls her age arya had big
dreams and aspirations for her life
unlike other girls her age one of arya's
biggest dreams was simply to hear
when arya was seven years old while her
and her father were out running some
errands in downtown they happened by a
group of street performers playing
popular rock music
a large crowd was gathered around them
moving in synchronization a pulsating
mass of human psychology pushed and
pulled by invisible waves in the air
arya observed and pondered the scene as
she approached now at an age where her
youthful curiosity met an intellect that
was capable of contemplating nuanced
questions about its own limitations arya
only thought in terms of asl or american
sign language and so her internal
monologue was more or less the sensation
of moving hands making understanding
what she was witnessing on that street
corner simultaneously impossible and
fascinating without realizing or meaning
to arya stopped walking james quickly
noticed and stopped as well after a
moment passed james signed to arya
everything okay
arya didn't notice so james tapped her
on the shoulder which quickly jolted her
back are you okay he signed again
yes arya signed back beginning to walk
again after a few steps arya tapped her
father on the side with a sort of
innocent expression on her face that was
simultaneously frustrated with its own
innocence
what did the music sound like are we
assigned
her father thought to himself for a
moment then signed it was big and heavy
passionate very intense it made me want
to move my head aria paused briefly why
does it do that there's something in the
sound that makes you feel heavy
perplexed by the challenge of explaining
music without using sonic terms james
clumsily signed back it connects with
you it connects with your soul your core
it overcomes your whole body he grabbed
arya and sort of swayed her back and
forth gently arya had no idea what he
meant but indicated that she understood
enough by softly smiling and laughing
the two then continued on about their
day quietly remaining deeply affected by
the conversation
as arya aged into and through high
school she grew more comfortable with
being deaf adopting and treating it at
least at times as a positive aspect of
her identity
however she of course continued to deal
with its inevitable challenges and
continued to ask and wonder about the
strange auditory phenomena that she was
removed from
around this time she began to fall in
love with reading and writing spending
much of her free time engaging in
literature of all forms her favorite
being non-fiction about science
technology and especially music and
musicians captivated by the idea of what
music was how it worked and why it
seemed to affect everyone so strongly
she felt a strange curiosity longing and
almost spiritual mystique when she read
passages by the likes of writers like
arthur schopenhauer who wrote the
inexpressible depth of all music by
virtue of which it floats past us as a
paradise quite familiar and yet
eternally remote and is so easy to
understand and yet so inexplicable is
due to the fact that it reproduces all
the emotions of our innermost being but
entirely without reality and remote from
its pain
this object is directly the will and
this is essentially the most serious of
all things as being that on which all
depends
[Music]
on september 1st 1970 when arya was just
22 years old she wrote and published her
first book titled deafness and
technology the book was a non-fiction
piece about her experience with deafness
and the current state of technology in
the hearing aid industry in which she
discussed her hope and optimism for
technology's potential and assisting
with deafness and other sensory
impairments while interweaving her own
philosophy of life and view of humanity
a creature and her mind profoundly
capable of overcoming adversity and
achieving supernatural like
accomplishments
in the preface of the book arya wrote my
dream is unlike most other dreams yes i
want to accomplish many things related
to a family a career and so on but my
dreams also include everyday normal
stuff that most people take for granted
i dream that one day i will know what a
voice sounds like i dream that i will be
able to know when someone in the other
room wants me without them having to
leave that room i dream that i will be
able to go to dinner and understand and
follow the conversations i dream that i
will know what the forest the beach or
the supposed ambience of a room sounds
like and most of all i dream that at
least once before i die i will know what
music sounds like
i know this stream is far-fetched to
most and upsetting to some but that is
why it is a dream and that is why it is
my dream
they say you don't know what you are
missing if you've never had it but i can
assure you that this isn't true i am
proud of my deafness but from the faces
i have seen change from sounds i cannot
hear i know i am missing something and
if there's one thing my experience has
taught me that i want this book to share
is that whatever you are not missing
don't take it for granted
in arya's 20s she would graduate college
with a bachelor's degree in professional
writing marry her boyfriend tom and soon
have her first and only child matthew
deafness and technology would go on to
do moderately well ultimately spurring
her a modest career as an author and
contributing writer for a variety of
print publications her work was well
written and widely enjoyed but also
critiqued by some of the deaf community
as well as viewed as naive and overly
romantic in terms of serious
technological and medical understanding
as time would pass however despite the
medical and scientific consensus having
almost universally been in contradiction
to arya's hopes things would seemingly
begin to change
in 1972 a medical device known as a
single channel cochlear implant would be
introduced to the market the device
would utilize a single electrode contact
that was implanted into the user's
cochlea the spiral shaped cavity part of
the inner ear involved with hearing the
device would then provide electrical
stimulation to the auditory nerve fibers
and essentially allow for the
possibility of timing and loudness cues
for hard of hearing or deaf individuals
throughout the seventies over one
thousand people were implanted with the
device providing some of them with
speech reading improvements
however research still indicated that
the device was extremely limited or even
useless in most cases as it couldn't
stimulate different areas of the cochlea
well enough to differentiate between
different sound frequencies and so it
mostly just created noise
by the end of the decade it was still
largely believed by all experts that
something effective of this nature was
impossible
but for the first time the impossibility
was at least questioned
over a decade would go by
very little public progress would be
made in the technology and the single
channel cochlear implant would seem
especially for individuals like arya to
be more of a problem than it was worth
in 1985 however a company called
cochlear limited would release the first
ever multi-channel cochlear implant
known as the nucleus 22. this device
utilized an intracochlear electrode
array that consisted of multiple contact
points which as more time passed and the
technology developed further would allow
for the transmission of different
frequencies including ones relevant to
speech
for the first time in human history
differentiated sound perception in deaf
individuals was made possible
on december 3rd 1991 after lots of
research debate and sleepless nights of
contemplation at age 42 arya would
undergo cochlear implant surgery and
receive the nucleus 22.
several weeks later arya sat in her
audiologist's office her husband tom sat
next to her holding her hand her father
james sat in a chair behind them are you
ready the audiologist said and signed to
arya yes arya signed back
now it's probably going to be really
soft at first you might not notice
anything but i'm going to slowly turn it
up and then it'll probably sound pretty
strange but like i said that's normal
your brain will get more used to it in
time but just let me know if you want me
to turn it off at any point okay
okay
are we assigned back the audiologist
turned the device on and then up
anything
no
she turned it up more
a brief silence filled the room
then
arya's hands covered her mouth and her
eyes filled with tears
on january 3rd 1992 arya heard sound for
the first time
when everyone realized what was
happening there was not a dry eye in the
room
overwhelmed arya nearly passed out
quickly needing to be comforted and for
the audiologist to turn the device back
down
the device did not come without its own
difficulties and issues arya found the
experience especially initially to be
somewhat uncomfortable overwhelming and
even painful at times she spent a huge
amount of time and effort working with
her audiologist to properly deal with it
and better develop her hearing
processing which was not easy nor quick
moreover the quality of the device was
still quite limited and although it got
better over time arya still couldn't
hear normally nor could she to great
disappointment processed things like
music which mostly just sounded like
beeping and buzzing
despite the challenges and difficulties
though arya kept the device in and on
deeply grateful and elated over the
benefits and new life she now had with
some access to the dimension of sound
over the following several decades arya
would continue to live a normal life
continuing as a writer wife mother and
soon-to-be grandmother
throughout this time cochlear limited
would come out with several sound
processor upgrades designed to increase
the processing power of the implant
device and provide a more comfortable
improved listening experience for users
a couple of which arya opted in for
on february 23rd 2032
when arya was in her 80s one of the
processor upgrades coupled with a new
brain machine interface hardware upgrade
had the potential to effectively process
for the first time the pitch of voices
and instruments and the timbre of
musical arrangements
on july 1st 2033 when arya was 85 years
old she once again found herself in an
audiologist's office
with a flip of a digital switch the
audiologist turned arya's device back on
now modified with this latest upgrade
and then from a small speaker placed on
his desk played the song claire de lune
by claude debussy
a collection of sonic notes arranged and
stacked in perfect specific patterns met
at the intersection of chaos and order
meaning in meaninglessness inside arya's
brain
for the first time in her life on this
day arya heard what music sounded like
she sat overwhelmed and numb
what does it sound like tom asked after
a moment passed and arya hadn't said
anything
arya looked at tom with tears running
down her clenched cheeks that now held
open a smile
then she said
i understand the nature of everything
[Music]
thank you so much for watching this
video was sponsored by klima
one of the biggest threats the human
species currently faces which it is
simultaneously responsible for is
climate change whether it's flooding
wildfires weather pattern anomalies or
worse climate consequences are real and
looming there are many things we can do
about this many of which extend beyond
the purview of the individual but some
of which do not
individually together we can help reduce
even if just a little one of if not the
biggest problem facing this period of
history the problem however is that
knowing how to effectively do so can
often be convoluted intimidating or
seemingly ineffective with clima however
it's easier to learn contribute improve
and track climate healthy living and
climate action initiatives in one place
in as little as three minutes you can
calculate your carbon footprint and
better understand how to modify and
reduce it through various changes and
with an affordable monthly subscription
you can go much further by easily
funding climate projects that capture or
reduce emissions and plant trees in your
name track your progress as you go and
better yet invite friends and family and
track your collective progress as it
multiplies together
if you're interested in getting involved
in joining one of the most important
undertakings of this generation click
the link in the description below and
use code pursuit 10 after creating your
account to receive an additional 10
trees planted in your name
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
you